Xplosive claims by former Democratic
National Committee Chair Donna Brazile
are bringing attention back to last
year's presidential race in a new book
brazil reveals the DNC struck a deal
with Hillary Clinton's campaign in
August 2015 it traded strategic and
financial control of the committee for
fundraising and investment in response
President Trump Democratic senator
Elizabeth Warren and others claimed the
2016 Democratic party system was rigged
Brazil's tell-all book is called hacks
the inside story of the break-ins and
breakdowns that put Donald Trump in the
White House Donna Brazile is with us
good morning good morning how are you
I'm well it was it a fair fight between
senator Clinton and Bernie Sanders
I believe so look we had five candidates
in the race Hillary Clinton and no
question about it I ran a very strong
campaign she had resources in the states
that met especially those early states
she won three out of the four early
States and she went on to win more votes
in senator Sanders but my purpose and
looking into what happened was to find
out if anything happened that we did not
anticipate and what I learned was there
was a memorandum of understanding in
addition to the joint fundraising
agreement that happened the DNC's
ability to control his communication and
some of his financial investments and I
pointed that out that's not entirely
true Donna what happened was that in
2015 both Secretary Clinton and Bernie
Sanders signed an agreement with the DNC
right the DNC was deep in debt and they
agreed to help replenish its its coffers
no I was a vice chair at a party and I
had no idea there was a separate
memorandum that gave one one candidate
control over selected staff and three or
four departments now
it may not be illegal but I thought this
was a nominal agreement a struggling a
no agreement that when I became chair
when I figured out why can't I spend
money why can't I go out there and make
some other strategic investments and
because of this memorandum I could not
so I felt obligated as I told Bernie I
would at the convention that that I
would get to the bottom of it and I
found no instances that the party rigged
the process and I wanted to make sure
that Bernie and his supporters
understood
seem to suggest that you think it was a
fair fight that's why I'm surprised to
hear you say to Nora no it was a fair
fight your book seems to suggest that
you were bitter you're angry and on top
of all of that you seemed very hurt but
it doesn't seem like you think it was a
fair fight Donna you even called Bernie
just explain to him I found the cancer
here that doesn't show so I'm also first
of all I'm a member I'm a member of the
Democratic establishment and in terms of
I'm on the Rules Committee it is a fair
fight
we don't set primary dates they're set
by the states we set caucus all Bernie
to tell him why I called Bernie to
explain to him but there was cancer that
I could not destroy and I could not
destroy it because of this memorandum I
had two choices to make and I think
Bernie agreed with me one was to expose
it and expunge it and then disrupt the
party in September of 2016 or to wait
until the election was over where and to
rid the party of basically allowing any
candidates below Hillary Clinton did
something for the party that everyone
should understand the party was broke
and she gave the party a lifeline of
resources in order for us to compete and
that's what she did for the general
election let me shift to this but now
you're claiming that that Hillary
Clinton in her campaign treated you like
Patsy the slave well no I said I felt
like Patsy the slave I didn't say they
look first of all I want to I want to
correct the record because I've known
Gail for a long time she's been my
editor so she's tough but there's no
there's no question that I was upset I
was upset because we were hat this
country was hacked by a foreign country
a hostile country we were gonna we were
done I read the book that you were upset
with Robby Mook certainly you also sound
very angry with Hillary Clinton yes that
happened the hacking wasn't issue my
emotions at my emotions of my emotions
but there's no question that I was very
upset at the time because look I'm chair
to party I have I have a lot of skin in
the game I don't I don't report to the
Democratic establishment I report to the
voters and what I wanted to vote is to
understand and the people who support
the Democratic Party is that our party
was under attack we had to deal with a
hostile foreign government the hackin
and at the same time
- like most campaigns you have family
squabbles you guys settled on this one
other thing and I love these two women
with that tough all right of course no I
want to ask you the question about the
future the Democratic Party yeah when
you say that Hillary Clinton Barack
Obama and former DNC chair debbie
Wasserman Schultz stripped the party to
a shell for their own purposes
what does that preceeded charlie by the
words three titanic egos oh good the
Democratic Party has lost over 900
legislative seats we've lost over 50
congratulate exact to their own purposes
here's what you make strategic decisions
every time you're involved in a campaign
and it's and if you're only targeting
the 18 states in the District of
Columbia that could bring you to 270
electoral votes and you're not allowing
people in Louisiana Tennessee or
Nebraska that get resources yes I do
believe that you starve the party of
leadership you starve the part of
resources and that's one of the reasons
why I'm proud to say that Tom Perez is
is making a real important investment in
all 50 states and that's the goal to
restore the Democratic Party we have an
election day today not just in New
Jersey in New York City but election day
in Virginia these elections Matt and
everyone should get out and vote don't
you seem to be upset as DNC chair that
they did not take your advice you
reached out to Robby Mook and he said
they were concentrating on analytics and
data you wanted the emotion in the
energy yes they did not take your advice
isn't it up to them to decide how they
want to run absolutely and and and I
made it very clear I was I was chaired a
Democratic National Committee I was not
the campaign manager I was not only a
strategic cause I did not go to their
strategy meetings if this was there she
wanted to go no I did not want to go I
had enough on my plate you know Gail
I've had enough campaign experience I
did not want to go to the high command
of Brooklyn I wanted to be in Florida
and Colorado as I said in Pennsylvania
I wanted to be where the people were I
was I wanted to be with the grassroots
here's what I wanted I also wanted the
the the candidate and the camp in her
campaign to respect the Democratic
National Committee I was an office of
the DNC and I felt that my job was to
the Democratic National Committee which
meant all of the candidates not just a
presidential but the down ballot
candidates as well well you open the
book saying you didn't hear from Hillary
Clinton until February was busy and I
was she was quite busy and I recognized
that but you know what madam Barack
Obama continued to help us raise money
Joe Biden showed up and helped us raise
money and Hillary allowed us to to lead
the the party and good financial shape
okay all I can say is you're naming
names and taking numbers and uh at 57
were rushing at 11:02
57 with almost 50 years in American
politics I I want to tell my truth I
read Hillary book I loved it but this is
mob this is my story I hope people will
read it but more importantly I hope we
take this the the threat of hacking
seriously and that we will give and we
prepare for the next election thank you
donna brazile have to go fail now
wherever you like to buy your book